all right we are live on the youtube i'm
still dave rubin and it's time for
another friday panel extravaganza i'm
actually super excited for today's show
we are doing an intellectual dark web an
idw reunion but is it a funeral or a
comeback joining me our founder of
skeptic magazine and author of giving
the devil his due michael shermer
evolutionary behavioral scientist and
author of the parasitic mind gad sad
and philosopher and author of how to
have impossible conversations peter
bogosian
fellas
you're all back on the reuben report how
you doing
great
never been better
well
why what have you heard
well the world is falling apart that's
why i wanted to talk to you all guys
talk to you guys there is that but pete
i'll start with you because you've never
been better so before we get to anything
else you you kind of broke some news
over the last couple weeks you left your
job at portland state you had been
screaming for a couple years about what
was going on there and more broadly in
the academic sphere
and you just
decided to move on you want to just
count this out
i had enough i couldn't take it anymore
it was an ideology meal and i actually
want to take this opportunity to think i
feel like i'm
i'm um
i know gad's a very good friend of mine
michael's a very close friend of mine
dave you're a very close friend of mine
and you were all so supportive of me in
that time and so i'm really appreciative
but i just couldn't take it anymore i it
was just so
it was it really truly was an
indoctrination mill and i left with my
integrity attack i fought as hard as i
could i did everything i could but in in
the end it was just better for me to
leave
all right so you know what before we get
to the idw stuff since all three of you
have worked and do work at different
times on college campuses gad uh europe
and canada which has its own set of
problems what's going on at the
university level there is is it still in
the same sort of meltdown feeling that
we have here
i mean it is in that i was just
complaining i was lamenting to my wife
that whenever i look at the emails that
i receive that are university related i
i'm not joking if i told you that
probably 20 30
are going to be related to walk related
issues and so it's you almost feel like
you're in a bizarro world where all you
talk about is you know indigenous this
bipoc that for those of you don't know
the bypack acronym black indigenous
people of color so it's just grievance
grievance grievance self flagellation
and you know you i long for the day
where i receive an email that's talking
about some you know wonderful
intellectual pursuit that the university
is engaging in
regrettably these are not coming very
often
michael you're over at
chapman which is here in crazy
california but i think it's been a
little bit better over there on the free
speech side of things is that is that
fair to say
yeah no our president danielle's troupe
is pretty friendly to
the kinds of ideas we talk about in the
idw and in our shows and so forth very
uh pro-free speech but of course he only
has so much control he has a board and
you know we just hired a dean of
diversity equity and inclusion
and for the life of me i can't figure
out what he's going to do because
chapman is one of the most
students so just incredibly liberal
tolerant open to diversity equity and
inclusion they are super inclusive so
i'm not sure what the the problem to be
solved there is but
he's just following along with what
everybody else
in the country is doing not just in
academia but in corporate america of
hiring people to
ferret out every last fraction minute
tiny little bit of
bigotry racism misogyny etc even if
maybe it doesn't even exist just
something that's adjacent to bigotry
racism and misogyny and
and that you know that's kind of a
common trend if you walk around college
campuses you don't see
um
you know just kind of a non-stop um
protests and and and the breaking of
starbucks windows and things like that
uh you know there's
a certain amount of the availability
heuristic at work when you know if you
just watch tucker carlson in his you
know crate campus craziness weekly
segments it looks like you know that
college is
completely melted down and if you go to
campuses you just don't see this most
students are just holed up in their
dorms and they're hanging out at the at
the starbucks or whatever and there's
not much happening at all
uh but nevertheless the the you know a
small percentage of
activists
stoking
emotions can seemingly take over
uh the uh you know the conversation that
way and so that's
you know that's still a problem we have
to you know we have to still stay on top
of it and uh i keep thinking the
pendulum is going to swing the other way
my wife and i've had these conversations
we have a five-year-old and he just
started kindergarten and we are worried
about critical race theory and vocalism
and all the gender stuff infiltrating
his schools
and my wife's from germany uh six seven
years here now and and she's been very
worried about this and i keep telling
her every few months this is gonna swing
around the other way i'm i remember
seeing these things go on for decades
and it goes back and forth it's gonna be
fine and she keeps asking me when's that
pendulum gonna start swinging the other
way because it looks like it's going the
wrong direction yeah i'm afraid speaking
of speaking of the pendulum i mean
that's sort of what put us all on the
map in a bigger way about four or five
years ago when the intellectual dark web
thing kind of came together and it was
sort of an accident and it would the
name idw which came from eric weinstein
was kind of a joke it was sort of you
know kind of tongue-in-cheek but it was
basically
all four of us were part of this group
of people who were on podcasts and
youtube shows and joe rogan and
obviously in my garage is kind of where
it started where we were just talking
about stuff and we were talking about
existential stuff and we were talking
about political stuff and philosophical
stuff and religious stuff and all of
this without hating each other um flash
forward to 2021 it seems like all of the
things that we were warning about have
gotten significantly worse
did we kind of fail in a way i mean i
hate to say it but in some respect did
we was there any chance we could have
stopped any of this gad
uh i don't think we failed i mean uh
you could only deliver the message and
if people decide to not heed your
warning it's kind of like saying uh if
i'm a physician and i keep warning
people that you should not live a
sedentary life and you should exercise
and you should not eat french fries
three times a day and they still do it
well then you know is it on me that they
developed heart disease and diabetes so
i think we've done our part i sleep well
at night knowing that
whenever i have the opportunity to
contribute to the battle of ideas i'm
certainly doing my part each of us here
is doing their part uh i do think though
like what michael was saying earlier
about the pendulum swinging i do think
that at some point it will start to
swing and i don't think it will take as
long as people might think for things to
autocorrect i think the problem remains
that the silent majority and i'm sure
you all receive thousands of emails
is completely on board with our ideas
the problem is to get them to activate
their their intestinal fortitude if not
testicular fortitude
to to speak out once that happens i
think the whole ship can be redressed
very quickly so i remained very
optimistic
pete i mean you left your job so it's
not like you didn't put your career on
the line because of all of this are you
as hopeful on the pendulum thing i'm
still not sure i mean we've all been
saying oh it'll correct at some point
you know they'll come to the real world
these kids and the
real world will show them what's what
but that pendulum seems like it's
breaking off one end and just going but
i mean i guess it could come around in
that case but you know you put your butt
on the line for all this there's no
question that it's gotten significantly
worse
it gets worse month by month and i'm
like michael i keep expecting some kind
of a correction and then more instances
of craziness come out and more crisis of
confidence in the system you know
michael mentioned the diversity officer
i think the key thing to to know is that
those are offices in search of tasks
and it's not
uh whether or not racism occurred it's
how
racism occurred so you have
institutionalized nested within these
academic bodies and institutions the
constant perennial
search for any kind of
racism even if it doesn't exist
i don't
here's what i know i'm very confident
that this ideology is not sustainable
i'm extremely confident about that what
i don't know is when the expiration date
is and what damage it will do to our
institutions along the way because it
has taken a considerable
toll
i i don't i don't know
uh but i will admit fully that even i am
surprised that it keeps getting worse
and worse and worse
michael i mentioned uh gab go ahead no i
throw it to michael i was just gonna say
i mean there are real consequences
beyond sort of the the you the typical
stuff that we talk about about this you
know all of these parasitic ideas in
filter infiltrating the university so
i'll give you a concrete example from my
personal life
it is now impossible for you to apply
for a scientific grant if you don't have
a die statement a diversity
equity statement and i know many people
some who are you know very principled
people who said that i am going to
refrain from applying for a grant
because i am so vehemently against
participating in this you know die
statement bs right well those are real
consequences right i'm not saying that
every single research program is a cure
for cancer but someone is deciding that
after all of the training in their life
they'd rather not participate in the
research endeavor if it implies that
they have to be complicit in playing
these walk games and so these are real
serious problems and we really truly
have to resolve them as soon as possible
yeah and of course gat in that regard i
mean your history of growing up in
lebanon during a war and being a refugee
that eventually made it to canada you
don't count in any of that diversity
stuff you're
that's probably because you're up in
canada right now your tan is real low if
you were in socal you're a little darker
maybe maybe you get some credit but
michael you mentioned you have a
five-year-old and just before we started
this uh here in california you're in
california as well
they are now announcing uh newsome has
just announced uh vaccine mandates for
all kids at school from grades seven to
twelve and they're recommending it
for for five-year-olds uh to i think
what was it five and up
um
how do you feel about that sort of
specifically for your child but also
more broadly that the government is just
saying who has to be injected with what
when
while it seems at least to me pretty
unclear whether any of this stuff is
working as promised
yeah i would i'm not going to get my
five-year-old vaccinated at this point
um you know there as far as i know from
the science you know he's in the lowest
risk cohort there is
well we found a
essentially a homeschool montessori
school in santa barbara here that's
independent
and they there's no masks and you know
they're not socially distanced it's it's
a small school but um
so you know it's one thing to recommend
it's another thing to mandate
um i certainly would be against the
latter um particularly in
in cohorts like this where it's not well
known what the effects might be on a
five-year-old seven-year-old whatever uh
certainly older adults and you know my
wife and i are both vaccinated
double-vaxxed and that you know we we
wear our masks where we have to here in
santa barbara where it's required you
know i don't want to be that guy that
draws the line in the sand like that guy
last weekend i think it was an american
airlines flight he decided
he had had enough with masks set 35 000
feet up and stood up in the middle of
the of the island confronted the flight
attendant like this is his moment well
you know he's in jail now so i don't
want to be that guy um you know i do
think there's you know there's value to
the vaccines certainly it doesn't look
like the masks at least the the flimsy
little cloth masks that most of us wear
m you know the m95 mass is that right
m95 anyway the 95 masks they seem to
work much that's a little stronger than
the flames
yeah yeah they seem to make a difference
but for
you know just in terms of who's most at
risk you know children are the least at
risk for both getting the covet and and
the effects of it on their bodies so um
it seems weird that that has become the
emphasis now there was uh a meme going
around the other day of show you know
three panels the top panel was the u.s
open audience you know 15 000 people
packed in there no masks and then a nfl
game you know 50 000 people packed in no
mass and then school children here they
are socially distanced desks are six
feet apart and they're all massed up you
know the least uh risk uh
um
you know cohort versus the the higher at
risk it's it's the i think it's the
inconsistency the hypocrisy of
of uh government officials and mandates
and recommendations that bothers people
the most you know there's multiple
reasons for for vaccine hesitancy but
that's one of them and particularly here
in california you know as you know
newsom hasn't been very consistent to
say the least and and at least uh
hypocritical that i think it drives
people away from listening at all too so
pete
what do we do with that then because
that's what i'm struggling with more
than anything else i would like to trust
the experts i really would i would like
to trust the scientists and at some
level i'd like to trust the government
people i really would but to me they
have failed at virtually every level
period the fouchy emails where he's
telling his friends don't wear masks
when they're on vacation while he's
telling everyone else to wear masks then
he's telling people oh no don't wear a
mask because you touch your face more
then he's telling people to double mask
you know newsome of course going to
french laundry with lobbyists while he's
locking the rest of us that the trusted
class the trusted class has basically
been obliterated
what are we doing
that's the problem it's also the
perception of hypocrisy i just want to
go back to something michael said i'm
very surprised to hear that you did not
vaccinate your five-year-old so so
what's the reason for that is that
lack of insufficient longitudinal
studies or or what
well yeah exactly uh i mean this the
recommendations that dave was talking
about you know they just came down what
yesterday what here we are october 1st i
think it was september today yeah
you know so
you know i'm going to definitely wait
and see i mean we you know we are very
isolated here where we live the school
is small you know the chances of him
being exposed at all are very slim and i
just want to see what the risks are of
the vaccine itself on children we just
don't know i mean it's it's too
preliminary
but but not only is it preliminary
there's just no evidence that
five-year-olds are getting coveted all
over the place and spreading it to each
other and spreading it to their parents
and the teachers we know are vaccinated
and in most cases the parents are that
that's what i'm concerned about that
nothing is making sense anymore
can i could maybe jump in uh
you know one of the areas that i study
in my scientific work is uh psychology
of decision making right and if you want
to talk about someone is rational or
irrational there are certain axioms that
you look for so for example if i prefer
car a to car b and i prefer car b to car
c i must prefer car a to car c if i
don't do that i'm being intransitive i'm
being irrational well when i see so to
build on what michael was saying when i
see the haphazard nature of how these
edicts come down from above when i see
the inconsistencies when i see as
several people have mentioned the
hypocrisy it's not you don't have to be
an anti-vaxxer you don't have to be an
anti-science person to then
build hesitancy towards the vaccine if
only because it all seems so irrational
so hypocritical so seat of your pants
type of policy making so i think if if
we were able to do a better job at truly
having a dialogue about these issues
which of course we can't because then
we'll be censored and so it becomes a
catch-22 situation so people are walking
around with a great sense of frustration
because they truly feel that they are
living in a authoritarian period and
that's not good for anyone so michael as
a guy that's uh you know made a living
being a skeptic i mean are you sort of
concerned that the idea of skepticism is
just disappearing either people are just
checking out they're like oh i don't
believe any of this and then going down
whatever rabbit hole they want to go
down or they've just decided they're not
going to pay attention to anything or
they're just going to make whatever
decision is based on their whim because
uh you feel like you're going to get
banned if you if you don't go along with
you know the party line
yeah that's right we just did an issue
of skeptic on on this very topic with
steve pinker on our cover you know are
we living in a post-truth era
well for starters if you just asking the
question means we're not because you're
the people that argue we're living in a
post-truth era are making an argument
which means they're not living in an
opposed truth era they still think
reason and arguments matter
uh that said i think part of the problem
is
in addition to the normal cognitive
biases that we're familiar with the
confirmation bias and the hindsight bias
and
and and
availability heuristic and and and uh
the anchoring effect and things like
that
uh the my side bias i think has gotten
much worse in the last well since the
2016 election things have become so much
more polarized that people evaluate
evidence based on whether it supports
their side or not usually politically
this used to be more prominent in
religion whether it supports your
religious beliefs or not
now um it's more politics and worse not
not just on the right of course the the
trump effect but also on the left i mean
woke-ism and progressivism and
anti-racism these are all uh you know
faux religions as you know john mcwarner
and pete i think you were even ahead of
john and making that analogy
that it's like a religion you know we're
we're all born in original sin
uh of being uh subconsciously racist and
bigoted and misogynist and so on and and
the only way to atone for it is you know
is to basically castrate yourself i
think you talk about this again in your
book uh you had that that word that
castrato i think of
people anyway uh you know i i think that
my side bias um
is so strong now that it it taints all
uh evaluations of evidence claims in the
media so we don't really trust the media
and back to the idw one of the reasons
for that um i think uh movement start
anyway was just pushing back against uh
mainstream media or
a legacy media uh you know if we can't
trust them who can we trust well we just
have to start our own systems and uh and
of course that has its own fraughtness
because there's you know a lot of most
podcasters and bloggers don't have fact
checkers and editors and you know so
that's problematic also
but nevertheless it's it's a trust issue
it's a my side bias i think that's
affecting most of our thinking on this
so pete with that in mind since you
wrote a book about having impossible
conversations i think i've discussed
this all with you all separately but my
thinking at this point is that at the
end of a purely secular society that
only is based on enlightenment values
and and sort of the the pinker ideology
that you are going to get this crazy
sort of nothing is true
men or women 3.5 trillion equals zero
that if it's just only based on logic
and reason you ironically get the most
illogical and irrational world which
sort of seems what we're entering in i
know i'm speaking to three atheists i
think ad you're still considered an
atheist but we'll get that a second but
pete what do you think about that that
basic premise there
yeah i think it's false and i'll tell
you why it's
the societies that don't do well they
don't as michael's book bend the moral
arc toward justice for martin luther
king societies that don't do those tend
to be more religious and michael is
correct about the parallels between
locism and traditional religion and the
structures that they use like blasphemy
laws and political correctness to keep
beliefs in place so
that
societies when they become and and
i'm thinking of you know the civil
rights act or i'm thinking of even birth
control for women
or americans disabilities act those have
come about precisely because we've
become more rational and more
evidence-based and so i believe and
my guess is that gad and michael do as
well that you can rationally drive you
can basically sit down and and think
about what kind of life you ought to
lead and what's the best type of life
and that there are correct answers to
that question those that gets back to
socrates and and the republic he talks
about that quite a bit and so the
question is how do we
come together to make
those lives where we can all flourish
the problem in which we have now and
then all related to the idw in a moment
is that we are unwilling or unable to
have conversations with people because
everyone is looking at different tribes
as an existential threat
so how do we how do we do that
especially when our university system
writ large
really doesn't encourage those kinds of
conversations for example why isn't
there a conversation between leaders in
the blm movement and police tactics
people who actually teach police tactics
i recommended that to someone and they
said what are you effing crazy we could
never do that
so we're not seeing that behavior model
for them and i think one of the original
the freshness of the idw was that people
really were having those conversations
there were no speech restrictions
on those
people were engaging each other and i
also think that's one of the reasons why
your podcast is so successful and
rogan's is because people are hungry
aristotle writes about that that people
want to know
all people want to know i think it's the
the first line of the ethics
and so what do they do well one of the
ways they get to know is they they want
to talk to people who have different
ideas they want to challenge themselves
they want to be challenged and challenge
others and if you take that mechanism
away what happens well nothing good
happens
right and by the way pete i actually
agree with your premise there except
that here we are in this place right now
so i agree that i would prefer that a
society do it and i think when times are
good america had 200 years of furthering
of liberalizing in the true sense to get
to equality but now it seems that the
hyper secularization or something has
jumped the gun on that go ahead and then
i would throw it again
real quick so
here we are the reason we're here is not
because we've assured religion it's
because we've adopted
we've become religious we've become
religious in a new religion in in
woke-ism and we've adopted a similar
architecture and similar structures to
to traditional religions that's why
we're here is that we've abnegated basic
principles of reason dialectic discourse
conversation counter examples belief
revision all of the necessary
constituents of rationality given the
attitude
yes so gad is that is that sort of proof
of what your last book was about the
parasitic mind that the parasite got in
and and my argument is that the
rationalization world the rational world
just wasn't strong enough so here we are
um but the parasite got in one way or
another
and so i'll link your question to what
you were mentioning earlier about the
idw i think what my book shows is not
only that
uh the idea pathogens that i you know
enumerate in my book all stem from
professors but the members of the idw
without mentioning any that you would
think are all committed to truth to the
you know intellectual diversity to the
scientific method they too can be
parasitized uh by various idea pathogens
and that's been my biggest
disappointment and that's why i wanted
to frankly disassociate from some of the
folks because
if you are a true intellectual there has
to be a bent towards deontological
ethics right there are certain things
that are absolutely incontestable that
you're never going to yield on so for
example if you truly believe in freedom
of speech you can't be a
consequentialist and say well i of
course i'm a strong believer in freedom
of speech but not when it comes from
that for that ogre trump if you are a
true person who believes in presumption
of innocence then that has to be a
deontological position it's not i
believe in in presumption of innocence
but not when it comes to the gang rapist
brett kavanaugh and so seeing these
types of violation of deontological
first principles
and people turn into grotesque
consequentialists on such important
issues that has been a big
disappointment when it comes to certain
members of the idw right so gad you know
i'm i'm with you on that if we're going
to be quiet when you know where
regardless of what we think about alex
jones's opinions if we're all going to
be quiet when he's silenced well of
course it wasn't going to stop with him
and then if we're going to say thank
jack when donald trump is banned
we're sort of being inconsistent michael
should we have all done a better job on
on that at least defending some of the
people that maybe we didn't like
i don't know
i think most of us spoke out i i was not
in favor of banning either alex jones or
donald trump even though personally i
was kind of glad to see alex jones go
because uh
you know so so much of his stuff was
harmful but see that there at some point
when it becomes a crime when he he his
actions lead his followers to go to the
homes of the parents of the sandy hook
massacre children
uh families and and harass them well
that's not a free that's no longer a
free speech issue now you have uh you
know actual laws being violated there so
you could defend
alex jones's freedom
to have his own platform
and and say what he wants but you know
there are restrictions to free speech
that are already built into the laws
that we're pretty familiar with libel
and slander and
and uh you know you can't you can't just
give the nuclear codes to the north
koreans of of our nuclear weapons that
that's not free speech that's treason
you know so there are a number of
built-in legal already restrictions that
have been played out in the supreme
court over the last century
i want to just add here i think
um you know how bad things are well
again to this my side bias and there's
also a selection bias of what thing
what items people want to be skeptical
of
um so i think of different kinds of
truths like empirical truths things that
we can actually test and know but then
there's political and religious truths
things that are not really knowable in
some empirical sense but people believe
them
anyway and i think a lot of political
and religious beliefs are safely parked
away from empirical truths so when
people say they believe them
they don't mean believe in the empirical
sense uh i was writing about this in my
next big book on conspiracies q anon you
know the idea that there's a secret
satanic cult of pedophiles being run by
hillary clinton and tom hanks out of a
pizzeria in washington dc no one can
possibly believe that i mean one guy did
edgar
edgar welch he went there with a gun
because that's what you would do most
people left uh you know like a one star
on yelp for that pizza place you know
and and one guy wrote that that the
pizza was too doughy and it was
undercooked you know that's not what you
do
if you think there's an actual pedophile
ring going on you call the police you go
there yourself
um and so i think most people don't
actually believe that it's a proxy truth
for something else like i don't trust
democrats i hate that hillary clinton
so such that for example if i point out
there's no basement at the pizzeria the
comet ping pong pizzeria there's no
pedophile ring there and you and i go
there you're not going to go oh in that
case i guess i'll vote for hillary you
were never going to vote for hillary so
the the conspiracy theory is just it's a
stand-in for something else the
uh and i think a lot of conspiracy
theories are like that they're they're
proxies for something else but such that
when someone like me comes along to
debunk the jfk conspiracy or the 911
truth conspiracy it isn't the debunking
that matters the facts are not relevant
it's it's stand in for something else
michael i'm reminded of when we spoke i
think it was at university of arizona
and i asked if there were any nazis in
the crowd and a woman in the back raised
her hand and it turned out that she was
a trans nazi
and she asked you about how at i think
if she was talking about auschwitz or
one of the concentration camps they
didn't have doors and that proves that
the holocaust was a hoax you calmly
explained to her uh why they had moved
things for different reasons and i'm
pretty sure she didn't uh you know turn
in her nazi card after so i think that
proves your point
yeah that's right so you know holocaust
denial it's not about the facts
you know that uh uh you know how many
jews were killed and and how do we know
and and the and this you know the gas
staining on the gas chamber at my
donaghy the blue staining from from the
zyklon b it's still there you can go
there and see it uh and on and on it's
not about that it's it's anti-semitism
it's about concerns of american support
of israel it's it that's really what
it's about and they want to kind of
under uh uh kick under the the
foundation of what they think is the
foundation of american support for for
israel and and jews is is this you know
holocaust thing
they're mistaken about that but that's
that's the thought such that if i point
out that in fact the reason there's no
holes on the ceiling at gas chambers two
and three at auschwitz birkenau this is
the thing that david urban used to talk
about no no holes no holocaust you know
and you go there and you see well the
nazis dynamited the the gas chambers
there's no ceiling at all much less
holes it's just rubble
um you know he irving didn't go oh i see
okay in that case there was a holocaust
therefore maybe
you know the jews are not that bad or
whatever maybe they didn't lie about
this no no because it was never about
that
that's a that's an excuse to you know
buttress a belief that you hold for
other reasons are you guys sympathetic
to the people that get hit with the
parasitic ideas or go down with the rat
down the rabbit holes and all of that
because i i actually am quite
sympathetic to them when we see a
mainstream media that lies about
everything the covington kids are racist
brett kavanaugh is the serial rapist
jesse smallett was lynched etc it's you
know the russia hoax everything i'm very
sympathetic to the people that get led
down these pathways or or hit with bad
ideas um and i you know i want to help
them as much as i can it's why i do my
show the way i do it um but i don't
blame them in some ways gad
well i guess i i would rather the
distinction when you talk about
narcissism you could talk about benign
narcissism or you could talk about
malignant narcissism right so when it
comes to people who are parasitized by
these bad ideas i guess it depends on
whether they're just hapless victims of
these ideas that take a hold of them or
whether they become malignant in how
they uh react to being infested with
these ideas right so when when you have
someone who is trying to consistently
tag your university because you dared
criticize serena williams because
therefore that means you're a racist
then i don't have any sympathy for them
i think they are a cretinous fool and uh
i want to go after them but you're right
that in some cases that you know if you
have a a poor student who is simply
being parasitized by a professor because
you think that your professor is the
purveyor of truth then i'm a bit more
sympathetic towards them and i try to
reach out to these people that's why i
also do what i do so there is a mix of
parasitized people some are malignant
some are benign peter are we making some
headway with these people
yeah in one sentence they're they're
epistemic victims but in another sense i
really pity them i mean how horrible to
live your life like that
how horrible to base your relationships
and your friendships like that and
what's interesting to me johnny depp
just came out against cancelled culture
because he himself evidently there were
attempts to cancel him and so many
people friends of mine have come out
recently against cancer culture and such
but it's never that people or very
rarely is it that people come out
against an injustice plato talks about
that it's not the fear of doing but of
suffering
uh wrong and calls forth the reproaches
of those who revile injustice in other
words it's always when these things
happen to you then you then speak out
against them but you don't speak out
against them before they happen and so i
that's incredibly frustrating when
people see that but they really are
epistemic victims you know their their
moral mind has been overridden by the
rational mind and gad is absolutely
correct those are parasitic values i
want to throw
something in it's not come up in the
conversation but it really irks and
annoys me
people constantly just listening to a
podcast today about the universities
that become liberal and liberal and
they're making the no it's exactly the
opposite the universities become illegal
yeah yeah yeah and people are throwing
around so this is not a right left issue
right this is we're teaching people very
dangerous ideas and we're not teaching
them and we're not even modeling for
them basic values you know like michael
has written about before when someone
asks you a question and you don't know
you just say i don't know and we've
really created these cultures of
pretending so no i i actually am i i
don't harbor any animus to these folks i
really feel bad for him yeah all right i
got one more for you guys and i just
want to say before i get to it that it's
been a pleasure talking to you guys
again and we really haven't done much on
the political front really this is this
was what the point of the whole thing
was um my last question uh michael
you're in cali dad you're in canada pete
you're in portland i'm in cali these are
all places that are hurting right now um
the the either the state or the country
the city whatever it is um are you
hopeful about the place that you live
and then just more broadly about the
west to survive this thing michael i'll
start with you
oh i am i am hopeful i'm i'm optimistic
i i do think sir the surveys generally
show that most people citizens for
example
are against critical race theory being
taught in schools and
yesterday i had jason reilly from the
wall street journal on my podcast and he
was citing studies showing that most
blacks
do not support critical race theory they
don't think the police are out to kill
them they they don't want to defund the
police it's black elites and then white
intellectuals and in general in academia
who say these things
um
and so i think if enough of us keep
speaking out
you know in kind of the intellectual
realm
and the academic realm against this
it'll make it it'll that will turn the
tide of that that small elite that are
that are pushing these ideas and that
well maybe i think embolden the average
person to speak up you know stand up and
say no we we've we've had enough of this
and uh so there i'm optimistic
well crazy cali
yeah i mean two you know
democrats vote republicans 2-1 here so
it's it's hard to see how that's going
to turn around anytime soon we do have
another uh election for governor in a
year and a half i guess something like
that it's unlikely a republican would
would come come to power but you never
know i mean things uh things have
changed in texas over the decades and
other states as well so it could happen
we'll see you know it's not a bad place
to live
in terms of the at least the weather i'm
not crazy about the taxes
yeah the weather is better than the
taxes uh gad you're in uh canada which
has still some like strange lockdown
stuff it's hard to get out it's hard to
get in
uh on top of the fact that they're you
know we're seeing videos they're
arresting people for protesting covid
mandates all sorts of stuff
how hopeful are you
look i am hopeful again because i think
that uh you just need to light the the
the match so that people find their
courage uh i speak to innumerable people
all of whom are very frustrated but yet
they always have an excuse as to why
they shouldn't contribute why they
shouldn't throw their hat into the ring
why it's too dangerous for them they
might lose their job i think that once
people in unison or semi-unison start
finding their courage i truly think many
of these problems will go away but until
we do i mean it's a classic what's
called an economics tragedy of the
commons right once we resolve that
problem
i'm very very hopeful that the ship will
be redressed so be hopeful be optimistic
there are better days ahead
i probably should have ended it with gad
right there pete you're in portland i
have a feeling it's going to be a little
tough to be so rosy
in the city of roses
yeah no i it's i was actually saying to
this to you before we went on every day
i mean literally every day you can see
it if just two or three the
deterioration two or three blocks from a
house there are maybe 300 homeless
people who have rented erected tents
the mayor of portland is a public
disgrace his grotesque incompetence in
the way that he's mismanaged the city
and the murder rate going up two
thousand percent and his attempting to
or his um
disbanding the gun reduction task force
because they said it was racist it
pulled over uh
more african-americans the consequence
of that is that we had more dead
african-americans
so as long as our current mayor is in
office i see no hope whatsoever for
portland i see only continued
deterioration and crime it's really a
cesspool of crime and needles and trash
and filth however i'm incredibly
optimistic about western civilization we
have
there are values that we have in this
country that are worth fighting for
reason is fighting for
due process is worth fighting for
cognitive liberty is worth fighting for
freedom of speech freedom of the press
and they don't evaporate the moment you
get slugged and you will get slogged and
we are getting slugged and what we need
to do now is we need to punch back and
and we need to stand up and we need to
teach a generation of people what it why
they should stand for the flag not just
that they should stand for the flag but
what that means but by that but by in
the same breath we also have to teach
that there's a kind of liberty that's
unique to this country this country
really is a shining city on the hill and
we've lost that and we've forgotten that
and we need to re-remember
why the values that we've created that
people have died for in the freest most
open less racist country in the world
those values have sustainability they
will last western civilization will last
that's right-wing maniac pete bogosian
everybody pete you finished us on on a
good note this thing could have went off
the rails but you took us home uh guys
it was it was really great seeing the 3u
again and i hope we can do this in
person over over drinks and steaks
sometime soon uh i'm going to finish up
without you but have a good weekend guys
thank you
that was sort of why i started this show
in the first place it was a long time
since we've done one of those and you
know i know we could do probably a much
deeper autopsy on what happened to the
idw and you know sort of those the magic
years of 2017 to 19 or so uh that you
know i was on tour for a good portion at
least a year and a half of that with
jordan peterson and literally got to go
to you know something like 20 countries
and and thousands saw thousands and
thousands of real people who were
turning their lives around because of
sort of some of the ideas that we talked
about here but in the case of being on
tour with jordan it was about fixing
your life first before you fix society
which then you can get to some of the
stuff we just talked about there
but i will just add one thing which is
that pete's ending there is right there
is something worth fighting for here and
it feels like it is under assault a
minute before we started this show i got
the news about vaccine mandates for
california students and it's like the
ever encroaching hysterical
authoritarian ideology it is here we
cannot pretend it's not here right as
god would say we can't be the ostrich
with our head in the ground just
pretending it's not here because then
you just end up as a beheaded ostrich so
we have to confront it we have to say
we're here we're going to fight the more
parents that stand up at school board
meetings the more of you that will
whatever it whatever the fight is i
don't even mean to make this just about
vaccine mandates or anything whatever
the fight is whatever they're
encroaching
uh on in your life that you have to
fight for nobody is coming to save you
but you yeah there's some people that
can talk about this stuff online but
like that's it and don't think the
government is coming to save you and and
just in the last you know two weeks or
so here in california and i get it you
know i talk about california because i
live here at least for now it's like i
get that it's screwy but in the two
weeks since the recall ended the first
thing they did was add more uh mandates
related to restaurants here in socal
that was one thing then gavin newsom
signed an order that all of our
elections will be through the mail you
think that might have something to do uh
with you know allowing more and more
fraud and then finally today with we're
going to inject five-year-olds otherwise
they can't go to schools like it's
coming it's coming and and figure out
how to fight it in your own way i will
keep fighting with you and other people
will keep fighting with you but they
have to know you're willing to fight
that is my message on this friday i hope
you have a good weekend you know what no
politics this weekend for anybody join
us at
reubenreport.locals.com we're gonna
we're gonna cook some stuff we're gonna
smoke i think we're smoking a spatchcock
chicken tonight i'll even put video up
of it at
reubenreport.locals.com let's share some
uh you know music and food video games
sports outdoors taking a hike that's
what we'll be doing over there we'll be
back on monday thanks for watching
everybody have a great weekend